et pour en parler nous recevons bruno
morel directeur général d'emmaüs
solidarité bonjour monsieur morel merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation
alors on le voit ce rapport de la
fondation abbé pierre est assez alarmant
15 millions de personnes sont concernées
par cette crise de logement 4 millions
n'ont pas de logement
vous serez mal-logés pourtant le
gouvernement au même moment inventé
son plan le joueur d'abord qui a été
lancé par emmanuel macron en 2017 avec
des résultats positifs
qu'est ce que cela vous inspire oui vous
l'avez dit les chiffres sont inquiétants
c'est la 25e édition à vos chiffres il
faut rajouter 2 million cent mille
ménages qui attendent un logement social
et c'est vrai que des efforts mais les
efforts sont pas à la hauteur des
besoins
la politique du logement d'abord vous
avez des associations et la fondation
des pierres à puis 7-7 cette démarche
le problème c'est que sa mise en
application est encore poussive
notamment si on prend que le sujet du
besoin de logements très sociaux à coût
abordable
on arrive à atteindre les objectifs
grosso modo on arrive à construire ce
qu'on appelle les logements pédaler 35
des parents l'état s'était fixé un
objectif de 40000 en faudrait beaucoup
plus mais c'est vrai qu'à solutionner
rejoint ben est une vraie réponse mais
mais tout ça va demander du temps il
faut vraiment envie de mettre la
priorité sur les logements très sociaux
sur la fluidité dans les structures
d'hébergement
il ya aussi des efforts il ya quelques
quelques résultats mais ne chante pas la
hauteur des besoins
surtout ce qu'on appelle
l'intermédiation locative et puis aussi
sur la création d'outils à taille
humaine de type pension de famille alors
on a pris en compte ici le manque d'
espace mais aussi la précarité dans ce
rapport la précarité qui touche
aujourd'hui 1 français sur 5
c'est dû à c'est dû à quoi selon vous
tue plusieurs raisons il ya d'abord eu
effectivement une massification de la
pauvreté il ya le fait qu' effectivement
l'air quel clavier très dur vous savez
moi ce qui me fera peut aimer cela était
on gère des centres d'hébergement on
s'aperçoit bien que des gens qui étaient
à qui était avant l'emploi était protégé
la précarité et que maintenant l'emploi
ne protège plus la précarité des
personnes qui sont qui ont des petits
emplois à temps partiel cdd se
retrouvent dans nos structures faute
faute faute de solution et puis ce qui
me marque un peu c'est cette espèce de
l'opposition convoi chalet précarité en
ce moment
on parle d'une crise des migrants c'est
une crise des migrants qu'on a c'est
crise de l'an dans l'accueil et on voit
bien que la puissance publique est
toujours en train de changer un peu ses
priorités pour pouvoir répondre à tous
les besoins famille contre personnes
isolées et d'ailleurs le rapport fait
cette année à zoom sur la situation des
des célibataires qui est très
inquiétante
et puis migrants contre sdf et c'est
pour ça qu'il faut maintenant aborder
tous ces sujets de front et trouver des
solutions
une des réponses par exemple on est en
très vive hier on est en trêve hivernale
on voit bien que les expulsions
locatives augmente d'année en année et
ils 3% sur les augmentations en allant
sur les derniers chiffres il faudrait
que le gouvernement s'engage au 1er
avril au moment où les expulsions vous
recommencez qu'il n'y ait pas
d'expulsion avec concours laveur subi
sans qu'on mobilise une solution c'est
absurde dû remettre les gens en larmes
dès 2018 a été une année record
c'est ce que pointe c'est ce que pointe
de la fondation et ils ont raison de
pointer ces choses ont pas tous de
prévention des expulsions locatives et
vraiment il faut travailler dans ce sens
là mais là on va avoir une échéance au
1er avril
eh bien nous ne faisons pas un ne
remettons pas des gens la rue il faut
impérativement trouver des solutions
contenant une souche on est dans une
période assez tendu une crise sociale et
un ras-le-bol chez les français on le
voit des manifestations quasi
quotidiennes
il ya cette crise ddd gilet jaune vous
voulez parler de cette crise migratoire
également s est résumée en accueil du
nom accueille exactement pareil je crois
qu'il faut pas il faut pas laisser
passer ce message là comment est ce que
vous pensez que le gouvernement peut
réagir surtout que ce rapport estime que
les années à venir risquent d'être
encore plus alarmante
écoutez moi ce qui me frappe on est la
sixième puissance économique mondiale
cette histoire il affaire de tous il
faut impérativement que le gouvernement
que les collectivités
que les grandes institutions que les
associations se mettent autour de la
table et dans le calme certaines salles
comme ça une conférence de consensus
on arrive à traiter cette question du
sans abrisme derrière la question de
l'accès l'ex un logement dans le panel
de 2,2 de ce que vous évoquez il
contexte un peu difficile il faut aussi
se réjouir de certaines mobilisation
positive
la nuit dernière s'est tenue la
troisième nuit de la solidarité qui ça
ça s'est fait avec des parisiens
volontaires 7 me qui sont allés dans les
rues de paris pour aller à aller à la
rencontre des sdf dans l'idée c'est pas
d'aller à la rencontre
ça c'est bien la voir le montage et dieu
sait que ce comptage 90 mais ça près de
construire des solutions et on voit bien
que ce genre d'initiative se fait à metz
s'est fait dans grandes villes il
et on voit que c'est ce fait se fait
avec la mobilisation des des citoyens
dont j'apporte un petit peu d'optimisme
sur le voilà votre votre inquiétude ceci
étant dit il faut rester extrêmement
vigilant sur les politiques de l'état
nous sommes très inquiets notamment sur
tout ce qui se passe autour de la paix
avec vous une idée des fameux 5 euros de
réduction et là une réforme de l'apl qui
devrait
être appliquée au 1er avril prochain qui
aura des conséquences pour à peu près un
million deux cent mille bon ménage et
qui fera que en gros de la moyenne
on pense qu'ils perdront 1000 euros par
an d'appel
tout ça pour un changement de mode de
calcul donc si ces sujets acquis qu'il
faut voir il faut arrêter les
restrictions budgétaires notamment sur
ces sujets très bientôt et merci
beaucoup monsieur bruno morel d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation j'aurais pas
que vous êtes directeur général a déjà
eu celui d'haïti merci